rtmps just don't want to work this
morning just like uh
someone killed all the internet it was
um
it was ubisoft they did it
viral marketing yeah i mean it's
effective it's effective
so
um
i did want to play a little bit of this
before
we got going here
over the weekend but i was uh i was like
single dad this weekend so
turns out me and my six-year-old did not
start the beginning of far cry 6.
i mean that's you know that's good
parenting right there we did i don't i
don't think it's appropriate we did
well i appreciate that i need to hear
that quite honestly to know i'm doing a
good job we did uh finish ratchet and
clank which oh hell yeah was was great
and uh i had never finished miles
morales
and my kid is now
jazzed about this spider-man game let me
tell you he is freaking out with it
what's up january we have some
uh yes tastef has uh gave me the green
light so i'm gonna give you all the
green lights
all right
so we can just start because why the
hell not right
here
so we're saying goodbye to you jen is
that the deal
oh yes yes yes yes hold on one sec
stream freaking okay yes yes yes we're
good
yeah
uh folks are saying game audio is just a
skosh hot if you could turn that down
just uh just just a little bit
i did a little bit
uh is that a little better for everyone
there
please uh speak up if it uh is or is i
know i need to hear more
than music cuts out right when i uh i
did that there we go pick mac up
right there we go here like
it's pretty low music bed right now so
yeah yeah well no more when you hear a
gunshot
people saying i'm a little out also let
me bump myself up a tiny bit
all right it's better
conflicting reports here
all right
everyone is quiet nobody's quiet the
game's too loud
hey i'm talking now to
i just don't know how the game is going
to sound until i get a you know
something yeah i know this is going to
be a little bit of a work in progress
here
we'll figure it out folks
all right we good to go
yeah jeff do you want to like come up
from a black screen into this
uh i'd have to do that huh
yes
[Music]
i could maybe just do a
what what about a picture what about a
fun picture no
we cannot i'm this is way too precarious
right here
all right maybe do
a black screen like that
oh no and then come back
oh that was scary that was scary i
didn't like that well yeah because
you're not your voice cut out as well
and i thought the whole thing it i mean
we're held together with duct tape here
look this is an international
transatlantic stream okay this is a
different kind of stream than your
normal domestic uh travel stream
i also feel like a parent leaving their
children at home alone yeah this is this
is
and they have to like cook dinner with
20
yeah like good luck little kid hey
everyone it's far cry 6 time
my name is jeff bakler i'm joined by
matt rory what is up matt rory hello
i like far cry i like all these games
yeah i'm interested to hear what you
think about this one lucy james is also
here
hiya
how you doing
i'm doing all right thanks how you doing
i'm all right i'm interested to start
this uh this game far cry 6 from the
very beginning
and this already i'm already seeing
something that i've really never seen
before
uh
we have an option to go to action mode
or story mode
and i feel like
a what's the difference b
[Music]
like
does this is i guess story mode is
more
i dare to say pedestrian
so you use a lot easier i assume yeah
you take less damage and you recover
your health faster action mode is
i guess the quote-unquote standard mode
yeah classic far cry experience all
right well that's how i've always been a
classic far cry guy i guess i don't know
i am curious to see what sir i can't
imagine story mode's gonna like
eliminate other experiences uh lucy you
started this too right
i did i've i've been playing it uh over
the weekend and i'm playing it on action
mode well i'm gonna do action mode
myself
um
well this is playing on xbox series x in
case you were wondering
i was just about to ask um so
there you go
um
i did not dig into any of performance
settings if there are that this is just
like straight out of the box
and we are going to see the very
beginning of this here video game rory
you've played all of these far cry games
how you feeling about this one yeah i
think i even played what was that weird
xbox one they had with the claws the
beast mode one oh in instincts evolution
yeah i play all these games i really do
like them a lot of i've loved i stand
before evolution of them over the years
the last few have felt a little samy
a lot of people are saying it looks kind
of but you would like to say me to um
the
modified with the purest
our enemies will never understand so
what are their jet packs
in some preview shots or something like
there's some weird mobility stuff right
now but i haven't uh i haven't been
watching so many trailers with renewed
phones um i just thought
i hope we can get through some stuff at
some point there's some of the openings
are there
i definitely saw something in this game
lucky yeah where to get them out but i
could be chosen i could be random
lottery
let me know if this is too loud
[Music]
hang on but you get one pretty early on
run off to the jungle with a bunch of ah
first person beer
best kind of beer for clara garcia's
local crusade come on this is our big
goodbye you don't want that third-person
beer
[ __ ] say something
all right i'll say something
let me just consult my
little identification here
oh
danny ross
hmm
okay
i'm gonna pick danny ross
yeah
oh that's neat
i got my name wrong
danny you could help libertad isn't
dating from us to dude from korean
military last year
just come with us i don't know if that's
intentional i i can't assume it would be
this game's probably been in development
for
five years now what's waiting drinks you
make
dinner in miami
whoa
uh-oh
see i always know what the like [ __ ]
the beginning of all these games i know
something awful and terrible is going to
happen it's going to make me upset oh
yeah
right out of the gate
god damn it
oh
oh god damn it
oh
all right let's far cry
no not yet people say
goodbye earn that i promise
all right
yes okay so
how how is it right can you little test
i've been playing on ps5 and if i hit if
i hit circle to duck
it's like a half second
like
before it even moves it's really weird
it's not very responsive i feel like i
got some good duck in right here i feel
like i'm duck in the way
i i intended yeah this is just like a
very organic natural duck
yep stair
don't want to start a game in a stealth
mode i don't i want to start shooting
[ __ ] right away um i'm not going to be
mad if this is like five minutes long
but still
i think i gotta avenge my buddy
i understand
yeah that happens she i kept losing her
in this section she just eventually
popped back oh there you are
what are you aiming at come on that's a
soldier
you seem occupied
let's go this way
this way yes
teleport where are you okay
oh [ __ ] i'm not resisting i'm not
resisting
i have a family
he wants us to watch the shadows okay
okay
can i can i no
all right well come on stop admiring
what are you doing let's go
he's hanging out hanging out oh boy
all right
the tank's gonna roll right yeah
we've all seen so many of these
interesters sneaking through like people
getting executed and everything i think
there's one of these in like black ops
and one of the like half-life 2 who's
kind of similar
um
they have their own rhythm and
narrative logic kind of builds in at
this point for games like
it looks like stuff it does look nice
okay
that's a lot of soldiers lita yeah
tom
all right
really just
dragging ass here
okay
i don't want that
white line there
where the [ __ ] are you taking me you
ever tried doing that on a ladder
there's you could not pay me enough
money to try that
that seems like the worst way to get
down the ladder right good gloves maybe
but do a minute i mean i think i might
have but i'm never on a ladder that
that you know tied to something that's
always been outdoor like lawn ladders
which are not suited for
is that do i not want to do this
wait uh
um
human height that i can just rip through
like this
get ready for a lot more of that
not really subtle but hey look this is
what this is what we're going for here
oh [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah
let's go towards the [ __ ]
oh man
almost there
the way out here
[Laughter]
you are sneaky
scared the [ __ ] out of me
supposed to be my friend
oh man
i like how they're going for like a
semi-realistic kind of seeing everybody
everybody get shot in the head before
you turn into a one-man army or
one-woman army and or carrying around 18
guns at the same time
oh
[ __ ]
what this is just like
i mean i get it i get what's happening i
understand what's happening
it's just far cry is happening right
like
just like [ __ ] boot camp
oh exposition she's been in the military
yeah good okay there you are
it's taking your time nice
oh you're right
that's a good question from the chat uh
what game has the most guns you can
carry at once oh i think
wake ward
back in the day before they started to
go into four or two guns at a time i
think um
god i think there's something like 15
but i'm actually curious if anybody has
any more opinions on that gta you can
carry a [ __ ] yeah
god i just feel like we don't have a
plan we're just sort of going wherever
the line takes us yeah it all leads to
the boat
jesus
just right over the firing squad i'm
sorry like
just
hey
yeah yay guess you can carry as much as
you can carry and fall out too so these
are the well no there is a weight limit
right
quick
oh freedom fighters also starts like
this
while i'm neglecting the freedom
fighters
you play freedom partners uh jeff no
no
we have to two on that boat
what the hell i'm gonna do with baseball
cards do you have any idea what these
are worth let us do
oh yeah
marco
always making new friends danny
where's alejo
stay very
very look i'll say it it's it's a bit of
a
that trite beginning in a way that i
it's almost tough to like feel something
you know
just seen it like a million touch yeah
that's that's my point yeah it's just
like
and i don't know when i don't i don't
wish to see it
oh yeah
this isn't right bunny
we should be fighting not running to the
young keys alejo gave you a [ __ ] gift
lyra we survived same as the orphanage
same as the academy chad is saying i'm
not very impressed with the
take
the generic take on this sort of subject
which
it's all in the purpose of getting you
into a spot where you can start shooting
people which um i thought that
the colts stuff in
the last couple was pretty good for that
i think that started out in a in a much
sort of different way where it was at
least
cut from a different kind of cloth right
like and this is all setting up um
what's up hey oh my god i totally forgot
the afternoon same soul setting up the
main bad guy who
at least seems
genuinely shitty and somebody i'd want
to actually take down
yeah he was el presidente me papa love
to fish
we would go out on a boat just like this
and we would catch the fish
and then
release them
he would say it's not always about your
stomach
it's about
the challenge
why not just kill this guy right now
like why can't we just do that
roll credits there you go you let that
fish go weird thing about giancarlo
exposito is that my wife uh says he
doesn't sound like a native spanish to
be her and i'm not
like it's the weirdest criticism she has
of my breaking bad big faces very
noticeable to her as somebody who grew
up speaking spanish that's kind of like
just off enough hmm
interesting
that's supposed to be your son his son
yeah i remember
oh don't do that why are you gonna do
the keep the kid stuff don't leave the
kids alone
i don't want this anymore papa we have
no choice
let them go
they can work make viviro
so vaviro is like the miracle can't of
the quote i i am making quotes in the
air the miracle cancer drug that has
somehow developed alongside tobacco
yeah it's like some offshoot from the
crops
we found the cure to cancer
in cigarettes
i don't know
yeah like dr robinson
recommends smoking two packs of lucky
strikes a day
he is going to
kill everybody
if they put this whole intro up on on
youtube right a while back yeah yeah
yeah i remember this from a um
[Music]
god
seems to be easier way to kill people on
a boat like use one grenade maybe and
not a million
i don't know that's heavy this is a
heavy-duty folks
at least it's not political
yeah yeah
oh she's she's 83 now
yeah wait she's on the beach huh which
makes you old huh
lita you do it they do it you did it you
did it
[Laughter]
she's hiding here oh don't worry you'll
wake up tomorrow
all your guns will be gone
and uh you gotta do it all over again
take my phone follow the code like when
we were kids stop it eat that
just wait i'll find hell no
you give her this
glad i will help you
oh boy
you're the lucky one danny
oh jesus
okay
you're the lucky one
my god
yeah
you're gonna hear that uh danny you're
the lucky one
quite a lot
i wanna say
luck does not appear to be a thing at
this moment
i
why if if this is lucky i hate to see
what unlucky is
[ __ ]
god do you believe it's six already huh
i know
all right
well we still got that basically i was
gonna say do you think do you think that
qualifies as a late title card i don't
think so that's a fail i think we're
barely 20 25 in
punctual sidelines
sure you know what i like that
i'm a sucker for that you know
okay get out of here bird what do we got
here
oh yeah and now we're far crying
with no
that's fine you know you can throw look
what have i got here
oh the [ __ ] is this still working
that's a great question
68
waterproof baby
whatever that whatever that is i don't
know
was it ipx
okay i don't know man
my phone stops working if i get it like
in the rain
yeah really that's yeah that's bad
that's not good
it looks like i follow the blue that's
bad hey hey that's bad ooh what do we
got here
okay all right
those parts
low armband must be part how are the
settings in this one the question from
chat so one thing i'll say is that the
accessibility settings on this are
really really good if you pan over to
system real quick you can change a lot
of things like you can remove
head bob you can change your quick time
inputs to be holding you can put menu
narration on you can put an enemy out
like so i will say finding enemies in
the jungle is quite difficult sometimes
so you can put like an outline on them
and get rid of um
drunken and drug effects yeah wow it's
really really cool the amount of
accessibility
um that they've put in
ubisoft does this stuff really well i
mean all their pc versions too are
always have a great menus great you know
setting stuff you can change and see
what the visual settings are going to do
before you actually get back in game
they put a lot of thought in their ui
and many steps
yeah they also uh menu narrations on by
default as well so it's like it's from
the very get-go cool love to see
oh there we go i'm gonna make some stuff
later
[ __ ]
i don't know but what are you aiming an
empty gun at
oh just you wait and see oh boy i hope i
don't have to throw it
i can smell it on your clothes
your sweat
it's this think of a traitor okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't tell mom don't tell mom
i didn't mean to come over here the
birds and the crap hey
you're just me oh go to sleep
you go here oh that arm doesn't oh god
no
i slept on it funny
this person was talking to a dead body
yeah i guess she was i was god oh
yes
that's cool
right away what's more impressive just
like absorbing the ammo as that happened
like
huh
i think she's dead
you killed her stop stop she's fine
i know that seemed you seemed like you
were crouching going slow ah
i'm sorry
but you guys are the bad guys it's not
me
what's this
oh
oh that's interesting so when i hit the
left uh d-pad i kind of like hide the
objective on top left that's interesting
change some gear
there we go let's do it put on her pants
this is very much the same ui from um
break points
kind of a little simpler but
um
did your pants have the one on them i
think
yeah there we go yeah you were naked
before shiny pants
hell yeah
that's cool is that is is was i can't
remember the last far cry didn't have
this kind of stuff right i don't
remember
i don't know that's when we crafted all
the weird weapons though so this might
be new i think this looks straight at a
break point
yeah and this one so if you you can get
different
uh you can get different i was gonna say
costumes for different outfit sets and
they give you different buffs and things
so
there's one mission where you can like
i don't know it makes you more fire
resistant and
you can just equip them
as and when you need them which is
pretty cool i think i mean new dawn had
i mean obviously far cry has been
getting in like a little deeper into rpg
stuff over the past few years and it
just looks like they're experimenting
because new dawn had
like
damage numbers and everything
all the games seem to be kind of
converging together in one they're going
to make one er oh dear that pig
crazy wild boar
skin
you can't him
him you just you just walk over him oh
okay
the way that skinny animation was a
little annoying from time to time yeah
from yeah especially when you yeah you
have to keep seeing it over and over
yeah yeah it should have been like a
fast skinning like a quick reload but a
fast skin
huh
oh well lucky for you you're getting
ready since i used one of these don't
worry it'll come right back to you
i can't wait to figure out how they're
going to squeeze um
we're going to sell a guy into this one
too he's been like a guest star in every
ubisoft game recently
sam fisher he showed up in
wildlands he showed up in something else
too i think he was in break point too
yeah i thought um of course those are
good ghost recon games but i i just want
him to be like the the ubisoft chair
that shows up in ever everywhere i'm
gonna show your face before you shoot
you will have the scream of ubisoft
there are there are i mean i'm only a
few hours in but there's already been a
few references to like other far crys oh
that's cool um so i wonder if they are
just going for that uh
ubisoft connected universe
oh man i can't have to play the rest of
the game like this
you are the only survivor i can skip it
but i'm not going to of course not
oh hello
oh
answer me i don't know why they've done
those title pages that's the one thing
that just like really all of a sudden
like
lock stock into smoking batteries
that's all you have to do guy richie
just dropping
cars up in here just a second
i'm getting the hell out of yara
well you're in my camp
i need a place to stay a few days
libertas no charity hermana lita said
you'd help
lita also said you weren't a [ __ ]
come here okay
it's
why
just kill her
i think she's one of the good people she
is a rebel
see yeah
funny how friends can be closer than
family
remember danny
castillo has kept you an orphan
we just got like a domino tattoo on our
left
order a whole boat of our people shot to
death
get as far away as you can from that
psychopath
all of you
when tyranny is law revolution is order
all right
we're teaming up right now
[Music]
where are the towers castillo's got what
three hundred thousand troops i count
six burned out geria's and you
with a bullet to the leg
you don't believe me
i'll show you
we launched an attack from our base to
this island was a basic operation
hit a vivid tobacco plantation snatch
some fuel and go home
but castillo's forces were waiting got
us down from 60 to six
you need to get back to your base
yes but this island is surrounded by a
blockade
we don't have boats we don't have much
gear west anderson you do this part of
that plantation goes up in smoke but we
are gary yes we know this land inside
out
you're already familiar with our
guerrilla paths it doesn't look like a
super huge island compared to some of
the other games but they're spread like
away
yeah there's more right
there's more okay yeah oh god this will
hide if the arm is like
they have this is a tiny survivor i i
was messaging jeff over the weekend when
i was going and i was like i zoomed out
and saw the whole island and i just grew
up more exacerbated
with the locals to get us a boat and you
need to go find me juan cortes
who someone who can make one guerrilla
fight like a thousand all right
do that
do that for you
is it
are we gonna see the
sort of icon barf again
and let me know when you want to pay
your rent
all right
so i just check in with you or
that
checks for that
money order
all right go shoot something
okay i mean it was like right over there
and now all right over here we need to
talk again
this is kind of neat though how it's
like
then
you and me are pretty different i click
the accept button and don't listen to a
word if anything anybody says in any
game ever
in any game ever destiny yeah i i i have
very like especially for like i've been
playing a lot of new world lately and
all those quests are they come with like
a little bit like three it's actually
pretty good to pretty streamline
clicking through them but
i know i need three boars heads i don't
need the the story of your mom dying
from boar head cancer
problem is we're not
talking about anymore
okay so this is
oh wait can you zoom out to the full map
yet
this is
wildlands-esque in terms of size what
that's why i got exasperated
what
that's big that's good
need some space to run around this is
far cry 6 7 8.
i'm curious if any that might be like
locked off or dlc or something like that
you can go in but i think you get shot
right away yeah you'll get
you think there's just a big geo fencing
you just
smash
they're not old enough to be in here
oh sick yeah let's get some gear yeah
chess gear
do the gear thing
oh yeah
expect that
hell yeah
equip it
done
move on
so is this having uh does it have co-op
out of the box i i thought i heard
something about co-op maybe being
delayed or something like that no i
think there's uh actually a couple
missions that
uh it gets unlocked i don't know if
we're gonna we're not gonna probably see
that in the time you have with it now
but it's it's not that much that you
have to play to to get yeah
i remember you get a thing that says
co-op is now online okay
people love that mode i've never played
one of these co-op i know some people
are exclusive to that so the spy [ __ ]
works clara i'll give you that
keep your gun holstered if you want to
stay out of trouble especially in areas
with a lot of solders see i got it a
smart area
okay
well it's a big tutorial for this hey
you gotta put that gun away
okay i
can handle that
there it is
car would be
cool
look at that motorcycle coming up i
think on your left
isn't that no like it's blurry to me
sorry i thought there was a car here
you want me to realize the place you
maybe you shouldn't go into yet yeah
yeah you might you might want to go to
the office yeah that looks like a
soldier outpost
can i slide yeah oh yeah there we go
slide all the way down here all right
look at
me whoa
you get quite a last line you really
have a generous runway with that let me
tell you
uh i guess the bars this way
that's some good environmental
love that love that design i love it
i hear radio
okay
uh
papers i don't have them on me senor no
papers
that's a series of things
hillary clinton
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry
go go
just
oh gosh
i'm gonna put your stupid body like
right
here
there you go
you're good you're good you're hidden
just sleeping off you sleep that one off
friend i'm inside the search then
oh there's a there's a wanted poster for
the guy
you're looking for
oh
there he is
oh damn a million pesos
okay
that is not
can't get in there
is this the bar
there we go
oh there you go that looks like a one
that looks like a juan
what
hey i don't know
what we're doing there drinking the
worst [ __ ] cantina in yara or is in
another guapo you listen rule 16 a
guerrillas revolution never ends always
another war another cantina
another ugly bartender
[Music]
and what was that shirt long ago never
took it was wearing you will too and his
little gold tooth guapo is amazing i
genuinely love that
if guapo doesn't speak
uh in this game i will be upset about
this is a [ __ ] i don't think guapo
can get in your vehicle though
what i know but he runs around he runs
alongside
um and he runs in very quickly
oh my god oh my god galapo
is a murdering machine
you [ __ ] rat
the world's more dead anyway
he just spit on his own feet but
oh [ __ ]
oh oh ah that's gonna leave a mark
oh no
what's happening
why did he need to cover up the sound of
the gunshot anyways oh he's covering the
blood spray back on his skates
lucy you have not done enough to warn us
here
hey hey kidding i'm kidding i'm kidding
it's like a hey i mean when i said it's
good they didn't play with this with
your kid i obviously was not going to do
that
wait for the gator to get to him yeah go
can i can i send the gator if you if
you've already gone
right on the d-pad
you can you can identify you can tell
grappler to go for a specific person
actually you might not be able to do
that just yet you might just have to
like get through this little bit but
then grappler becomes your
your pal
you know what lucy i think i understand
what you're saying with like the little
delayed ducking
yeah it's really weird right yeah the
crouching before wasn't
tough but now it's like it just seems a
little slow
yeah
i'm drunk but i'm not see ui is really
interesting it's really cotton kind of
minimal for a game like this like the
ammo counts really small and the mini
map's not too big i kind of like it i do
kind of like that too but i i the the
the variety of uh accessibility options
i would imagine you could change the
size of all right
because this car is [ __ ]
not happening yeah somebody shot it a
bunch i don't know who that could have
been i guess it was me
wants to be your friend
or maybe he just needs to take a dump
okay one way to find out let's see him
dump go ahead
get my pet hey guapo um and you pet the
alligators my handsome friend uh come on
let's get the [ __ ] out of here let's
just
chill
oh what did i what am i offering oh it's
a that is a
huh that came out of nowhere
suspiciously at hand to meet so maybe it
was the um the thing you were cat did uh
the hog you killed earlier oh right yeah
that's what it was yep we'll say it was
that yeah you're
you're a
it's a good achievement name as well
okay
oh nice can you pet the crowd yeah i
feel like they did a thing with that
with dogs last time right like they did
obviously the uh the friends sort of
thing is back where you can sort of just
like spawn in people to help you oh so
you can have different companions okay i
did like that uh mechanic from uh you
know fart five or new dawn or whichever
one um i always pick this
man the stealth by the cypre people it's
always my favorite
now you pet the alligator come
[Laughter]
one is here
i got more [ __ ] x's than your porn
search history oh man okay
one you old rascal it's only three of us
he breaks [ __ ] countries
where the hell are we going now
the size of his gun too jesus
one thing i'll say is that um
classic walking alongside an npc is
really annoying in this game
because they slow you down oh yeah i was
definitely
to steal [ __ ] the worst
they had that so much and days gone uh
dave's gone had some really really long
cutscenes that you just had to walk for
long like can't run can't move very fast
can't run a motorcycle
just walking my one frustration with
that camera always use the right tool
for the right job you coming with me
[ __ ] no oh you got guapo you can tear
[ __ ] up with him but if you want to be
sneaky leave him behind that cutie loves
to make a mess
he is cute
where are you buddy
come on here you go you yeah look at
this guys
yo
his like ryan gosling drive jacket is
pretty awesome
yo look at it it's like cut uh it's so
cool
man
this is the smart look at somehow this
is the smartest alligator on the planet
takes perfect direction
so you're going to go in louder or quiet
here
well i'm going to play it the way i
normally uh
play games with me
like this i try to start off stealthy
and then i
uh either allow some enemy to
you know hit an alarm oh hello
um
and
then i have to go gun blazing oh
whenever they see guapo they immediately
get on alert
they're not really uh
fans of alligators
disappointing of
them uh rory is i'm going to go in ha
yeah
oh sick
i guess this could be useful
yeah there's not that many
in that first one whoa this is really
taking me a while to steal this
let me tell ya
got it all right he needs two more
up here
oh oh a single shot that's nice is it a
auto or
i usually the
oh you can flip here okay cool yeah
i can single shot once myself
yeah
if from my call of duty memory the foul
was a single like i was just using
single
but let's see how this goes
all right i need
one more oh some folks are saying that
the um the frame rate's stuttering a bit
is that just because of the stream it
could be the stream i uh
it cut out for me for a second there and
then it came back so yeah it looks it
looks okay to me
[Music]
yeah the only thing i had on ps5 was i
had a bit of screen tag
um in particular found all your [ __ ]
juan uh intense
firefights there's like one
in particular where i was like
using the zip line to
come down a place from above and
firing a rocket or whatever just typical
far cry um and it i got a bunch of
screen tire but other than that it runs
pretty well okay yeah so far so good i
am running in 1080 but um
so what's with all this junk
you building something patience danny
rule number eight a guerrilla knows how
to wait
like a spider or a serial killer
so how did you get to this god for a
second whoa
i was on a refugee ship
yeah this is
it's annoying right not great it doesn't
i mean
it's just something you get used to i
guess i don't know no i mean what's your
story
and the military i'm no guerrilla i was
going this look at this i've never seen
one run before he's running where are
you going dummy
have you ever seen a turtle run no is it
hilarious they're very very cute very
funny
there is no other option
america is my option
of course
and you think america's one his laser
site is just like
why is he following me honestly like you
might as well just have like a shark on
land to follow me or yeah
you can trust waffle with your life
any uh empty acts in this game you see a
store or anything like that so far
anything in the minute
oh i honestly haven't looked um
i did find the sort of place in the
world where you access the you know the
the dlc was coming later on with vas and
pagan and joseph seed i found where you
accessed that
okay but i didn't see any micro
transaction stuff but honestly i haven't
looked for it i mean actually jeff if
you want to hit start maybe it's there
because there's like there's some
resources in the top
there's inventory
no
no
collection no collection maybe
oh wait no no the the shopping cart in
the top right oh
oh it's all the way over there
oh this is online store this is like
yeah check it out and see i want to see
what they what what they're selling oh
boy here we go yeah oh living in the 80s
look at a little puppy oh yeah
what
oh i guess that's like
another person friend that's yeah the
dog is the chorizo comes along later and
some dogs and
that's in every ubisoft all right
ubisoft i mean they did this for all the
assassins creed games it's usually
pretty ignorable if you don't want to
there's there's uh you know yeah uh it's
not that big of a deal to me personally
i know i know some people get really mad
about it but huh
listen to what
okay
listen to one i'm gonna run away from
you yeah there we go
all right
our camp
so you've been gaining xp is there like
a skill system in the game how many
others i didn't see one in the menu i
didn't see like a skill tree okay
but you do level up
okay
i think you kind of grow a little bit
more
it has a
you know if you're being a nuisance
sort of like a wanted level where you
get sent um
they send more
reinforcements after you if you
if you cause a lot of bother
powerful
time you learn about wrestler danny i
was six when i rigged my first bike with
a chainsaw motor whoa
the blockade means i have to resolve it
every day juan ah that's survival for a
guerrilla resolver isn't just making do
with what you have
is inflicting chaos
with everything you got
keep talking
okay
go ahead danny let's take a crack at
those weapons
no offense but your battle rifle is a
little basic let's fix that
let's upgrade your weapon rule number
nine always use the right tool for the
right job
in this case it's gunpowder and scraps
sometimes i lie awake at night asking
myself like one how can you kill people
faster excellent danny now you can pop
enemy flesh like a ripe watermelon okay
let's say your target remember to wear
their helmet and rest today you're gonna
need some armor piercing these rounds
fly straight in you know
yeah that's fine
this will turn a bang into a bang see
how easy that was now you can silently
headshot your enemies like a real
[ __ ] your workbench is your friend
danny
a friend with benefits
get closer
there's like a million workshops around
the uh
workbenches around the map by the way
like pretty much every single area that
you have an encounter in has a workbench
next to it
so they're really pushing this
i mean there was this
in the last couple games right like yeah
i think so yeah
shifting my chat
oh
dead animal
i feel like taking wapo for a walk
always i feel like that's your job
am i getting paid for this
danny there's an app for that buddy you
can find
alligator walkers and anymore
oh my god they've got
hamilton watches in this what is this
thing oh yeah i think i heard about this
they are doing some kind of uh
brand relationship or put it in your
pants oh no the brands they're coming
for our video games are coming for far
cry
oh [ __ ]
oh damn that's far
all right oh wait wait but you can you
can use a new mode of transport yeah
guapo
let's hop on
all right
go
1200 kilometers that way
uh if you head down
i'll be on motorcycle down here for sure
oh just you wait it better oh hey
hey what's up
what do you see
that's a powerful
friction optional and uh
la isla
there you go
uh one thing i'll say is that full
damage is not kind in this game oh
really okay yeah i have uh
i've jumped off what i thought was just
a light clue oh that's many times and uh
and just been
it's annoying i like i like a generous
fall damage in my games i like to be
able to jump off stuff i swear that was
the thing in far cry 3 like you could
buy a
a skill that just made you
well most of these games have that
parachute that you can use above a
certain level and if you are below that
level but not high enough to use that
parachute you're probably [ __ ]
yeah you don't get the
parachute oh there he is hey there we go
okay good
i'm gonna mount that no don't shoot it
you need to make some glue seeing
you're uh
trading for glue
okay
there you go
oh don't pet its eyeball that's not what
you want
everybody
i'm so lonely i just want to be ridden
been a long time since i watched mr ed
but i guarantee you that impersonation
is 100 percent
since basic training oh this horse
controls like a go-kart
okay
this is okay oh this is a little much
[Music]
uh they cannot take that cliff
whoa whoa there you go you don't need
this you don't need your field
okay
uh i just is there a turbo button
yeah
wow that's a lot of controls accelerate
the quick turns
oh damn
sorry i just broke your neck horse
just
oh my god you can follow me you turn up
the
other fov sliders for this it looks like
the fob is pretty snappy
you want me to adjust it you know check
it later i just want i'm curious about
all this guy well let's do take a look
at all the system options at some point
but
go shoot somebody right now but
if you go in the map you can set a
waypoint and so it's like a bit easier
to find the
the location because those blue lines
those blue roots
the gorilla forces
like private like secret roads to try
and help skirt around um
yo we are going like 40 miles an hour
right now
man
ah tyranny 101.
interesting okay we don't want that
that's a neat concept
yeah
bye
you see now one thing i noticed about
every time i go to a checkpoint like
every time i open a checkpoint and claim
it
the
every time i fast travel to one
an enemy will spawn immediately and
there's always a firefight just outside
it every time i spawn in it's
interesting i remember in far cry 3 when
you took over all the outputs the world
started to feel really dead because
there weren't there weren't enemies
spawning at all hopefully in this one
you can kind of still have some open
world encounters after that
so you can hold down a here to just sort
of put the the horsey on autopilot i
want to move it on foot around here
because i feel like you're going to be
coming on to a uh
bad guys here in a bit
a good boy okay i'll be back after i
murder a bunch of people
good horse you stay here do you keep
licking me we'll talk about that later
but
this i thought this edison oh no i put
the silencer on this one
uh
on the foul oh
maybe i don't think you made a silencer
no that's got a silencer oh that one
yeah yeah i would say that
i'm here too
i fall around the horse i would really
appreciate
some sort of
audio chime when guapo just enters
you know like the the pesky neighbor
funkadoodle says uh jeff acting like
tony soprano in love with his horse
while murdering so many people
that's very good
that's very very good
uh
i feel like i finally get that reference
now guys 20 years later
i found the tower
see i'm on my way
oh what
okay wait i can get [ __ ] up there right
whoa that is quite the toss damn
yep
don't mind me
can i take i would like to take this
oh
some fancy boots no i think you've got
full i think you got full get these
boots on
budget boots have been rocking
okay so okay interesting fugitive kicks
oh yeah
quick fingers quick feet improve speed
nice
anything oh yeah so that i think that
that number on the right um you see or
says one it says much terror yeah that
that's your kind of level and that
when you liberate certain things when
you
kill a bunch of people i assume
um
come on horse
no see i don't think you could call a
horse
there's an enemy horse to your left
do i have an app that i can just
the horse yeah all the horses are gps
chips yeah like
it's a busy little screen there can i
not interact with this that's upsetting
it's not like not the gta thing where
you can l one example
no
it's just like
when you when you you get sent pictures
a lot
and uh you can examine them
examine them in that and also instead of
having a pair of binoculars to scout you
use your phone camera and your phone
camera does it so if you tap up on the
keyboard
oh no there you go yeah
there you go wow hell of a zoom on this
thing
okay all right well look
that's okay
okay
see what we got here
oh great question from chad can you take
a selfie with guapo
wait hold on you you keep smoking now i
gotta
go
oh i don't think guaca can make it over
here yet no oh he's gotta jump he's
gotta oh we gotta see him make the jump
oh no he's taking the long way
i get it i get it it's a long way down
brother
we'll see you later
okay oh he's sliding he seems to be
sliding down
i'm taking the scenic route yeah i get
it i get it one described you pretty
well
my name is raiza and i'm going to be
helping you steal [ __ ] from castillo
today nice are you going to tell me what
i'm stealing depleted uranium
i thought you just said uranium you
heard me
look all i know is i burned my last
contact in the army tracking it down for
juan ux military isn't everybody okay
just show me where it is first you take
this parachute trust me it can save your
life now i'll take you to the old
spanish fort they've got it locked up
inside
okay sorry to aim that right at you
sick
what's wrong
nope just getting [ __ ] up in your little
perch there
hey there he is
going script you can take the picture
can you do this
are there oh no photos currently
available oh
[Music]
okay we're myth busting she's really on
your ass about this movement here yeah i
get it wow i get it's important okay
all i wanted to be was a soldier you
know where the uniform surf my country
found out the only kind of soldier
castillo wants is a blind fascist
addicted to his effort you're playing
this uh jeff and not me so i can just
run through it as quickly as possible
when i actually started
he can also give us useful info what
does he want from us one not to get his
ass shot so keep your gun holstered or
he'll open fire
okay these double agents will get us
military intel right
no weapons
oh
no photos currently available is more
about story content doesn't the photo
mode still work yes that is a good point
i figured because we were locked into a
mission that they were like you can't
putts around and take a photo but
this is a weird a weird mechanic because
i mean like um breakpoint had people you
could interrogate you had to shoot them
in the legs and let them drop down but
now i guess you got to keep them alive
and bribe them maybe you can still do it
if you shoot them with a leg
which is my preferred method of
approaching double agents just
constantly shooting people in the leg
yeah just touch the leg in case they
have any intel and then if they don't
you know bobbing and popping would you
just tell me to put my yeah she did it
and who are you aiming at
what is this
except for me
my friend is a little
anyway
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh man
yep i'll castillo i get it
okay
use your phone to schedule
soldiers and see their weaknesses i
think we're good for now he's already
giving you his right tool for that right
i do love the kind of like diorama that
they like put together there
uh okay
that's supposed to be mosaiced out i
guess um
okay
that little bit was really blurred for
you ryan yes yeah but it said tag
soldiers to reveal their weaknesses i'm
assuming bullets are usually gonna pop
up there yeah
wow hell of a zoom like i said that's
nice
uh
okay what's your weakness
you're
you're the okay armor piercing rounds
got it
i can't imagine i'll do it
any of this being useful i mean i'm
gonna
shoot people so they go down usually uh
i'm not gonna change between armor and
soft target for every alvarez has the
key to the person i'm shooting careful
danny he's higher rank in castillo's
army that means he's better trained so
this is weak against
can you go back to one of these guys so
we could get stronger against is that
what this
weapon rounds
yeah weak against weaponry okay
it disappears
you're gonna be right on top of that
dude
is that everyone
i doubt it probably more people in the
uh inside the base
yeah i think so all right
if you go to the right protected base on
the other there's like a little soldiers
have been issued with body armor a
little path there nothing oh yeah
like every time you see
yeah got it
all right well
that parachute i gave you could come in
handy yeah so you did make one of your
weapons
uh armor piercing one soft target but
i mean if you're actually
fighting two dudes with different
weaknesses and you have to switch
weapons that's gonna be kind of it seems
like it might be a little bit of a
distraction but i guess we'll find out
soon yeah but also like i feel
armor-piercing rounds would be
yeah
most people love it let me also kill
people who get shot without armor you
know yeah
oh that's cool
oh isn't soft target for animals
uh chat asks that's a good point yeah
because you can if you shoot
animals with i don't know i haven't like
explored them
yeah you get well you still get meat
from them but you get ruined oh it's
like
yeah
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
oh this is a lot this is just like the
stuff that i'm just like i don't i don't
know if i want to do this hey kids do
you like menus
it's just like
all right i'm going to hover over this
i'm going to go to the soft driver well
i just want to see the the readout for
what it says on it but the soft target
armor two two one more to your right
those heavy damages are an unarmored
target so that should be even good
against humans but um yeah go for them
do we like
i don't think it's specifically for
animals though i think they probably
work well on lesser wait a minute so
you're telling me i can't do this like
in the on the fly
no
you have to be at a work bench to do
this what
that's going to make sense
am i crazy or is that like a little
weird it's just you could do that kind
of stuff in the field in some places but
i can kind of get why they don't want
you to be
changing everything right away
instantaneously in the fields
right jump yeah wait where's my
parachute i forgot
you just jump and then hits um b
all right
here i go
guapo where are you
they didn't see me they didn't see me
all right
oh i should have put a [ __ ] optical i
don't know if i had enough use for it
but
if you go this way and go down the blue
path you'll probably be
getting pretty up close and personal so
better
what
what what oh did they see guapo oh no
guapo you idiot you can tell him to hang
back i think but oh he's with me
goddammit
yeah if you i think if you hold right on
the d-pad you kind of like just
just tell him
no he's like not doing anything whoops
he's daddy's on his way hold right okay
now i just okay now he'll stay
okay climbable perfect perfect there we
go
okay that was maybe not the best oh boy
oh dear oh dear oh yeah
how are you supposed to get over that
purse
maybe i'll use a probably a grappling
point on top of it probably a grappling
go look straight up look straight up
it should be right
yeah that's definitely a grapple you got
to swing across oh there you go
oh
i'm
hmm
because this first mission is going well
a guapo point i'm very good you didn't
see it
oh it's cause guapo's next to you
wait you're still here
we just want something near you man
apple go to your home
here yeah lounge you can tell them like
find your find your find your uh your
wheel for him you can tell him to stay
put i believe there you go come back no
stay whoa easy
how'd you do that
all right all right take two thank you
oh
amazing i didn't just eat it right there
okay so it's letting me go up this thing
yeah just gotta look at the grappling
point little swinging across guapo you
stay the [ __ ] still i swear to god all
right
um there we go hmm that seems okay
wow i am really good at just
okay and then i need to swing
wing
yeah everything's fine
i tried to jump
oh interesting maybe detach there we go
a little high oh
is cool everything is cool we're cool
uh yeah i'll turn that off
you hungry i actually was maybe like
they had some
some goodies in there
some fascist goodies
security cam okay security cameras sound
and alarm and call in reinforcements and
trigger stay out of sight or destroy it
okay
i guess maybe that's what that blue
thing is
yeah squat though
oh right what the hell where's the hmm
okay it's gonna be oh so
the uh
they're in in the uh in the coyote
i like this i like that you can like
push open a door how you want it to open
and not
automatically like
a little finesse that i appreciate
break in
up
he's on tv
really should have thought more about my
plan here
see i'm already noticing it is not super
easy to like just center on stuff and
collect it yeah you have to be really
specifically
placed
i can't go sneak up on that guy that's
what i'm gonna maybe attempt to do here
everything's cool everything's cool
oh jesus oh
throw him over the side of the back
ladder though that's what i'm gonna do
there you go
oh
hello
he was at the door oh yeah no oh this
guy yeah i saw him yeah yeah he's close
i thought okay make sure you saw
oh no you didn't see me
yeah
not anymore
nobody heard that wow
oh [ __ ]
nope yep yep
nope you didn't where's my camouflage
oh boy um
just machete kill him when it comes yeah
maybe stay behind the boxes
good thing i can smell the body good
thing i can see through walls
oh sorry
yeah okay
whoa oh your silencer is on fire now it
is yeah it can overheat
um
not a backseat game but i would
recommend getting the alarm
oh
guapo
oh my god this alarm
yeah
no
no oh you got it you're fine you're fine
you're fine
just shoot it
oh [ __ ]
god damn it
yeah
it's
guapo is a good lad all right guapo
you're coming in
can we do a guapo run oh
sure
i want to put if i can get a scope on
attachments
that's a good question does the
suppressor break if it overheats i don't
know i've never had one like oh i don't
i have to be better
looks like i need to be much better
is it not oh that's so weird this is so
weird
when i push up it like moves around
that's so weird
all right anyway
yeah yeah
it didn't work okay
[Laughter]
back to the drawing board i guess
hmm
all right maybe the move out of the gate
is to go for the radio tower
so let's do that guapo
um
i don't know
what you're gonna do
maybe i'll send you he can run
interference maybe you maybe you just
rock the front gate
because you are just fearless
yeah go for it i mean um
yeah it feels like it'll be quicker
either way
i mean guapo is like genuinely a re i
don't know why you would use anyone else
because guapo regens all his health and
he self revives
yeah he's and he's a straight-up killing
machine
oh overshot that oh
did it kill it
what is the bad thing about the tower it
calls them reinforcements yeah with the
alarm yeah
just shoot them too
i guess i love this gun
if you can get them inside the uh the
fortress they probably just walk through
a door and you can ping on the head all
right here it is
oh sorry
oh [ __ ]
wait is he
he's definitely walking towards
something maybe we saw guapo or you yeah
maybe
ah nice
that guy's going down
yeah
man i mean he's the
you could oh yeah just jump behind him
and uh yeah
oh go faster
no
how do you see me goddammit oh no no
shoot what the heck go home
guapo get in here what i have to smoke a
cigar
[Laughter]
oh boy
there he
get
is
people come and find you
she said oh no as you hit her helmet off
smoke smoke
heal heal up he'll hit heal there's yeah
yeah i think it's on the ground
oh boy they're coming for the front yeah
stay here and just shoot him as you come
in oh what do you got
must go faster
yep
oh boy
what a sloppy far cry i'm far crying
reptile metabolism okay
where are dude he better be there coming
in the front door
yeah they're coming in the front door so
maybe yeah look that way
okay he's down you're gonna have to do
some damage here
i would not i would avoid this big open
area to be honest with you i'd stay in a
little door and let them come to you
you don't have any um
yeah
um
oh [ __ ] yeah
nice
yeah they threw a grenade right at
themselves
hey that door saved your life
nice
you got a lot of people coming holy [ __ ]
you're okay good boy
yeah you must go now there's a lot of
three amigos
so you need the you've seen the uranium
and get out of here right
yeah
where is that where it is
it must be probably the bottom part of
this i assume
is it too late
there you go
oh in here yeah there it is
250 depleted uranium and just count like
that yeah i don't want this [ __ ] to
start popping off
oh you should just get on top and jump
out can't you
give me a lot there there are a lot of
people in here not this way right yeah i
know look at your mini map they're all
they're all out front
oh that's yeah well this is trying to
get them away from them yeah yeah
guapo's got himself a fire fight right
now
good luck lava hope you packed a gun
there you go this is perfect oh nice
clean
quiet and fun yeah
just like we drew up
wait
put it
guapo's fine ocean is he on the other
side oh he's on the other side of the
island you know you gotta run around i
have to i have to bring the depleted
uranium yeah yeah so that's going to be
a you get that car there's a car nick
that car
i'm sorry guapo i love you
all right
all right
i'll write you in the hospital
this piece
my horse is faster
oh oh we just saw we just we both we
both turned we both turned asleep at the
wheel no we i they turned into my turn
everything's cool don't worry
checkpoint didn't want to know what he's
going to do oh that was a soldier
this car
oh is this the checkpoint right
900 go to your map and tag it as a as a
oh [ __ ] somebody's behind you oh no
guapo is coming up
he's hurt
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] watch out guapo get them
get in
oh man
oh he's right there yeah
sorry
so you're saying i should go oh boy
this is bad huh
i think individually you can kill
soldiers you might just want to get
indoors and let them come to you is what
i
my
strategy
yeah you can use blackboard
all right guapo i'll meet you back at
the spot we what
what why is that oh you did you have to
destroy the billboard oh son of a [ __ ]
can i just destroy it from here
uh you can shoot it
or you can splash it with a um
later there you go
did it unlock
no
i don't think it unlocked
oh maybe you have to kill everyone
uh
something's happening right now i'm in
like slow-mo weirdness
okay we're good wow we did it we did it
i was a delayed reaction i think guapo
is back there killing everybody loving
raising the flag right now
all right you know what horses are way
better than cars in my experience so far
so
mm-hmm
oh there you go
first
one nope the checkpoint is clear
absolutely
there you go
let's do it
time to go to tahiti come on
did i just piss that guy off whatever
horses fist source alive
i mean we are booking it
i'm sorry but guapa riding a horse right
now would really just make me
smile in a way
well
we're about an hour and 20 in and i can
comfortably say that
this is a far cry game
yep
sure is far cry what we got here
folks
what we got here is a far cry game
we're just gonna skyrim our way to the
checkpoint
i'm like i'm smashing a like uh i'm
trying to
you know red dead redemption right
smash that a like you smash that like
and subscribe you know it
oh oh okay
uh just a little just just a little okay
we're okay parkour um
all right i'm going to leave you here
stranded on the top of us
you're on your own
big roach energy there
oh this looks
welcoming
oh yeah here's a weird [ __ ] coming in
here we go
danny should you be touching it like
that soviets left these six it's
depleted
in the 80s oh and they use it to like
tip bullets and stuff right or something
because it's super hard isn't that yeah
believe you'll be a [ __ ] superhero
danny
lita and i used to sneak this into the
orphanage essential reading while
waiting to [ __ ] up convoys in the mud
hege must be a sponge for inspiration
okay all right well you work with that
depleted uranium i'm going to find my
alligator
okay everything is getting oh is this my
jet pack looks like a man
see
she does that too
one more thing okay i want you to meet
tostador
title card
maybe don't do that right there in your
very flammable workshop
you guys saw
the
cigar used as a healing thing right yeah
yeah
that's great
you mean right over here
supremos aren't just simple tools i
built all these workbenches
what in the [ __ ] is on my back right now
oh it's a rocket launcher it's like a
mortar yeah okay i i saw the pictures of
it i thought it was a timeout timeout
i'm launching this thing as it's on my
back or i'm like laying this thing down
first no you're you're launching it from
her back i'm sure oh that's on your back
that's what i want the special
ingredient that makes this all happen is
pick a gadget danny this is a safe space
there's no wrong answer here
oh a baseball might work real nice
wait explain so you already have that um
so you have gadgets so you have molotovs
equipped you have baseballs which are
like rocks from far cry 3 right distract
enemies so this is basically
i'm sorry go ahead well you can oh you
can have throwing knives
uh what are the other ones the flashing
ones
there's a there's a smoke grenade a
molotov
a perception grenade oh it's just nearby
enemies dynamite a regular dynamite
so i guess i guess you everyone gets one
just just pick what you want
interesting
now go talk to class normal grenades
okay
interesting
literature here
yeah like you can not focus on anything
here
yeah you have to be like on top of it
and looking down in a weird specific way
such a pet peeve of mine
okay i get it you what do i look like a
[ __ ] priest
franco history is on our side history
will never stop the bullet it's just new
equipment equipment equipment and
weapons and gear
a history book never stopped the bullet
even if we get through it
they call it a wrist gear instead of
just watch
oh now you've got now you've got um
co-op
right
better than waiting for them to find us
and kill us here nothing brings you down
you ask for my opinion siri
i gave it to you
all right maybe we'll do one more
mission here
sure
yeah before we go we should take a look
at some tech stuff to you i've had a few
questions is there a performance mode on
uh your console version he's built work
to produce
no i swiveled around on my chair and
then i kicked my desk
oh
monday that monday feeling
well i could talk to these cigars or
that is weird
um
would you want to see matt uh just uh
maybe at the end of this before we go we
can take a look at some options i was
curious if there was a
was there a performance mode on consoles
can you change the fov
stuff like that i'm always curious about
the poisoned and drunk effects you can
turn those off yeah we could do that uh
so not a whole lot there
these are i'm sure are all consoles
yeah this is xbox series x
um hearing motor cognate what is
cognitive
i think that's like
certain um
things that like interfere with how you
sort of like perceive the game ah
that's neat like interactive on that
level
uh motion
there's a motion preset it's interesting
oh it's to decrease motion sickness yeah
caller's vision hearing motor
is maybe
i don't see the fov is there did i pass
it by
uh maybe it would be in vision i think
maybe
scroll down maybe
if our scroll up
fov would seem like something we'd want
to have as a setting in there but maybe
not hmm
i'll look on the pc version when it
comes out and we'll see okay
might have glossed over it but anyway
yeah yeah it might be in the summer that
i'm just not seeing
you again
oh this is crazy i'm like right here
yeah
if things get too heavy
just pull the trigger it's weird that
this isn't subtitled
yeah yeah
did i turn it off
what you'll get it danny
you'll get it
cool
don't worry i'm a friend
can i steal your horse i'm sorry
have you got those those thighs of steel
to hang onto the horse while you zip
line down
all right i i want to understand this
supremo thing better
it's just a
it's a special power so yeah you lb rb
you probably have a timer for the
cooldown a lot because you can't be
using all of them the more the more
people you kill the faster it recharges
all right
and then i just want to see if i could
pop on some sort of better sight
i don't think i oh i need gun powder god
damn it
all right
i'm assuming the other weapon too
yes
oh gotta give me some gun powder to make
a sight
all right
here we go
starts off slow
oh boy
okay
this is very precarious
you've got your um parachute right
parachute yeah
nice
hello
you think you can land on a horse whoa
don't tempt me
with a good time you're right
uh
you gotta say hi
i did oh is it not working oh from from
a very particular angle okay yeah that's
right
i wanted to do this alone but clara gave
me an order
don't give a [ __ ] i must have lita
she should be here right now but instead
i get you and i'm supposed to be in
miami but instead my two best friends
are dead and i'm stuck here with you
so
truce enough talk step one we hit the
tobacco step okay
we destroy their poison supply step 3
i don't want to listen to this guy i
just want to hang out with you dude and
more importantly castillo's [ __ ]
poison
all right i must have turned off that
stuff
somehow
geez facebook whatsapp and instagram are
still down yeah uh
the dns records were removed
from the i'm reading something about it
right now they're the dns records
removed from the global routing tables
oh my god even like
people working there probably aren't
getting email or anything else and all
their internal tools are probably down
so it seems like there's some kind of
major thing going on that's wild you can
change the font size
just uh
and you can put a background on it
as well i like that
i like that a lot
very cool
very cool to see
way go mitch here oh yeah let's rock
them oh you got it you got a full outfit
oh [ __ ]
oh
whoa this is what i've been running
around looking like
[Laughter]
look like a ghostbuster
what the [ __ ]
how
did i don't remember putting that on
i think that's what he just gave you
right and i'm just like on the face it
goes right away
all right i'll rock that scary [ __ ]
and then
where's my wrist gear
um there it is oh yeah where are your
mitts
there you go oh flame retardant mitts
what's up
dirty on
yo it's either the watch or the mitts
the using the right protective gear in
the right situation will keep you alive
okay so that's another layer here
i'm hearing that a lot lately
and i guess you're fine with wearing
what you're wearing sir julio
and if she loved you
well
that just says a lot about who you are
enough
look
if you and i are going to do this
you need to know about the poison you
mean that [ __ ] they spray on the leaves
its real name is pg240 well we call it
the poison because
i mean
what a wordsmith wow inspiration
sometimes like a poet right here like
deep down sick that doesn't mean
so you're military
marksman
what's your thing i'm good with guns
we get along we'll start thinking
that gear i gave you was good for fire
and poison but there is no gear that
fits their style no matter the situation
i hope this isn't some weird thing where
there's like different
enemy weaknesses you gotta switch
between a million different weapons
all the time i kind of just like
shooting people
up here die
this far cry's doing this now
golly
it really really wants you
to climb up a tower and tag people
oh yeah i make sense
i will never grab you
see ew
bunch holes in the tanks to let the
poison out into the air that's right
folks if you liked burning crops of
drugs in far cry 3
then guess what you're going to be doing
in far cry 6
it's back
they're hard it's back but it does not
have the skrillex uh damien molly's
in there put it on youtube or spotify
um play it along
as you burn these fields suck us up
before battle
a song
oh i lowered the music
ah yeah that's probably wise um i was
driving a car in this game and i did
start playing living in la vida la vida
location
[Music]
i don't want to see i'll guava when i
was deploying too yeah come on bud
nope
no no
no
as usual
equip your twisted or flamethrower
okay i guess this is just going to be
terrible though
i'm sorry
there you go
he's got a skull
oh i thought he was like high level
i was genuinely confused with this
because look you just burned that entire
little field there oh don't kill them
um and that was only two percent
towards your
sabotage um
still burning though it looks like it's
spreading
the fire the music's really adding an
interesting tone to the whole thing
yeah
maybe skrillex was too you know screw
likes maybe he's on that kingdom hearts
money now he's like no i'm not going
back
[Music]
only eleven percent
be careful guapo
be careful
[Music]
nice shot
[Music]
[Music]
it's all burned up
oh there's a lot of people in here
i could swear i hear music
[Music]
that's your friend that's your friend
that's your friend right my dad yeah
you're shooting
that handsome guy
[Music]
[Music]
you could try using your um oh [ __ ] yeah
do it wait i gotta help out
watch out my boy somebody right there
right behind you
i'm glad that's good
hey bud i'm sorry i shot you
and run and run
all right time to get freaky
i have a feeling you just need to burn
down the fields or else people just keep
on coming yeah but i want to use my
crazy i feel like where's the field it's
lb rb isn't it
i want to see the other fields this is
all burnt right yeah
uh oh here we go here we go
there's also tanks you can do
[Music]
[Music]
i would assume it wouldn't look so black
no i think i think you're right whatever
you've got most of this way this way
yeah
big yellow tanks
big yellow tanks
all right there we go
yeah they got back up so more people
would be coming in i don't think you
need to burn the whole thing though i
think it'll spread from plant to plant
once you start it so yeah
all right when they come in for
reinforcements i'll use my special
[Music]
they came in from this way before yeah
there you go here we are
oh my god
that's great that's cool what the hell
there's no aiming on that
it's just sort of like that general
vicinity
uh and the more folks yeah there you go
oh
that makes sense
of course the
gun
my gun can tell when you're killing
people and gets more loaded faster
[Music]
[Music]
of
petrol
uh
[Music]
[Music]
there you go
um
let's go save yourself
every man for himself
what the wait
now over here what the hell
okay
guapo is
speeding oh [ __ ]
oh on fire
get him guapo
okay dude
uh let's be let's do it all right both
head back to the large stone tower okay
i'm trying to talk to this guy what is
happening
i think you have to go back to the tower
behind oh yeah yeah oh sort the original
uh thing
okay to your left to your left yeah
that one now
[ __ ]
oh these two horses are here so bizarre
hey
[ __ ]
you really can hold your own i don't
want to say i told you so but
look we should move that was a hell of a
light show and they're going to see the
smoke we work well together see
listen if you were good with lita you're
good with me
gracias danny meet you back at camp nice
okay there you go
another successful mission
guapo's happy i'm happy
uh
i think that's gonna do it for uh
for this couple hours into far cry 6
everybody
rory lucy thank you so much for
for for being here and and and lucy
helping me
uh you know get my wits about this game
appreciate it
it's good i i think despite
the wonkiness of some of this i'm still
going to have a good time running around
shooting people i really hope my main
hope now is that there's not some weird
like
lightning fire ice thing where you got
to change your bullets every time you
get a different enemy because i
definitely saw that that last enemy
you're shooting really didn't take a lot
of damage you can see the smoke from
where do you want that's my big worry
apart from that i'll i'll i'll have fun
with this but
it does seem like more far cry which is
what everybody in chat's been saying for
two hours like yeah
sure is far cry but this is sure is uh
guapo and it looks like he's going to
craft something real fun
do you need a boost
he wants he wants to uh to mess around
with his guns he wants to change him he
wants to change his jacket
you can't blame him
yeah that tooth is pretty gnarly
uh anyway thanks for thanks for tuning
in everyone and uh letting us stream
some some games here for you
some of the beginning of far cry 6.
we'll probably cut this down a little
bit more uh for the site later on if you
want to catch a more condensed version
but you'll also be able to watch
the uh two hours or so
from the beginning and start of this
game if you wish to do so as well so
thanks everyone tuning in live and we'll
see you soon what's up yeah talk more
about this on the bombcast tomorrow
tomorrow 11am for definitely more far
cry 6 talk definitely for and stuff i've
been working on a history of far cry
with richard lee over on gamespot so if
you want to go back to the very
beginning when far cry was just a tech
demo
and then it got the mutants and then it
went all the way up to
to what we've been watching and playing
today then that'll be up tomorrow i
think on gamespot excellent quite the
journey
quite the journey oh yeah yeah ask me
about far cry at your peril i will bore
you with
anecdotes now
yep
no
all right jan says one word for the
entire quick look it's yep
yep
i didn't want to just interject on the
conversation you know i didn't i didn't
want to like oh look at guapo but guap
was pretty tight guavas guava right now
is due is like definitely 80 of the
get me the way there so
we'll see how what else this game has to
offer but
yeah thanks everyone this out friday
on friday or tomorrow seven seven yeah
okay so
thursday thursday
gotta get down on friday
by the way the supremo just cooled down
yeah you didn't
kill enough dudes you didn't kill enough
right i guess you can juice
the
the supremosa yeah the superior's
bloodlust still not stoked about that
thing firing off right behind my head
but nevertheless
all right take us out guapo
we'll see ya
nice boy
you